we're on problem 33 and it asks which
equation represents a line that is
parallel to y is equal to minus 5/4 X
plus 2 so a line that's parallel will
have the same slope and we can just look
at this we can inspect this and say okay
the slope of this line it's the
coefficient on the x-term
so the slope on this line is right there
so the slope is equal to minus 5/4 and
so we just look at have to look at the
other choice and say which one has the
same slope of minus 5/4 and choice a
actually is choice a is y is equal to
minus 5/4 X plus 1 so it has the exact
same slope and it's just shifted down by
one so a is our choice a problem 34 let
me copy and paste this one okay paste it
alright and they ask us which graph best
represents the solution to this system
of inequalities okay so we could take
each of these inequalities and then we
want to do is want we want the area that
satisfies both of these inequalities so
let's take a look take a look at the
first one and I like to always have it
in kind of y is equal to MX plus B form
so let's do that so we have the first
one says 2x is greater than or equal to
Y minus 1 if we add 1 to both sides we
get 2x plus 1 is greater than or equal
to Y and if we just want to write that
in a way that we're used to seeing it
why we drive been switching it around Y
is less than or equal to 2x plus 1 so
let's see which what which one this
represents we have a line 2x plus 1 so
the y-intercept is 1 and the slope is 2
so let's see so that's this line here
right y-intercept 1 and if we go over to
the right 2 we go up 4 right however
much we go to the however much we
increase in X we increased
as much with why and that's what the
slope tells us right and that's this
line in this chart like that fair enough
so that's that line and they're saying Y
is less than that so we want the area
below that graph right so it's not this
one right this one they're shading in
the area above that line right for any
X&Y that's on the line they're shading
in Y is greater than that point no but
we want Y is less than that point so for
any for any Y on the point all the Y's
less than it satisfy it so based on the
information now this one seems to be a
pretty good candidate I haven't looked
at the other line yet and frankly
neither of I guess no neither of maybe
this one might be candid because this is
also less than maybe we have to be less
than both of these lines right this is
the line that we just figured out we're
definitely less than it may be we have
to be less than that second line as well
so if we have to be greater than that
second line we haven't looked at that
yet it's going to be choice C if we have
to be less than the second line and this
first line then we're going to be in
choice D let's see what the second piece
of information it tells us okay well
they actually have a typo and they don't
give us enough information to actually
let me see if I can let me look up the
answer because they don't even they
didn't even write a greater than or
equal or nothing here so I have to see
what they probably intended okay so I'm
I just looked up the answer and they
said that the answer is C so they must
want us to be greater than this second
line greater than the second line so
let's figure out what this should have
been so if we you know what what should
have this should there have been an
equals well doesn't that an equal sign
but should have never been a greater
than or less than or whatever we'll
figure that out so let's see 2x minus 5y
circle whole ten right we don't know if
there's an equal there or less there's
almost a better exercise and than what
they intended okay so then if we let's
see if we were to add 5y to both sides I
just want to get Y on the other side and
I don't want to have to say flip signs
and divide by minus 5 so let me get 5y
no side so I'll add 5y to both sides so
we get 2
X whatever inequality sign is so that
could be an equal earn whatever
10 plus 5y good to subtract 10 from both
sides so you get 2x minus 10 circle 5y
remember that circle could be an equal
sign it's not equal it's either greater
than or equal or it's a less than or
equal and then we can and then we can
divide both sides by 5 and you get 2/5 X
minus 2 sum greater than or equal or
less than or equal sign Y now they told
us E was the answer because I had to
look it up because they didn't give us a
any inequality sign there if C is the
answer that means we're going to we want
all Y's that are below this below the
first line so below this line right here
so that's that area and if we're in the
square where all Y's that are above this
this bottom line right so if we're above
this bottom line this bottom line is 2/5
X minus 2 so we want all Y's that are
greater than that greater than that oh
sorry I've done it I just we want all
the Y's that are greater than that Y is
greater than this thing so that sign and
this problem should have been should
have been a less than sign right I'm
saying Y is greater than this but if you
read it left to right you have 2 X minus
2 is less than Y and so we figured out
the sign and you might be saying hey
wait how come this area over here
doesn't work right well if you think
about it this area is above our first
line this area is y is greater than 2x
plus 1 it's above our first line and
it's actually below our second line so
it's actually the opposite area anyway
next problem so the answer was C next
problem 35 okay let's see I'll copy and
paste this one I think the choices are
interesting
what is the solution to this system of
equations all right so let's see if we
can get it in a in a form that makes it
easy to look at so if we I'll just let's
take that first equation and let's add
3x to both sides if you add 3x to both
sides that first equation becomes
positive 3x plus y is equal to minus 2
right all I did is I did plus they you
can't see that I added plus 3x to both
sides of this equation and of course
that cancels with that all right and now
let's see that second equation is 6x
plus 2 is equal to minus 2 well you can
already see well let me let me do
something else to this equation I think
it'll become apparent that these are
actually the same line so if you take
this first equation and multiply both
sides of it by 2 what do you get C
multiply 3 X plus y by 2 you get 2 times
3x is 6x plus 2 times y you write you
have to distribute the 2 plus 2 y is
equal to minus 2 times 2 is minus 4 and
they're the same line same line so if
when you're solving a system of
equations you're figuring out where to
those two equations intersect if they're
the same lines they intersect everywhere
so they have an infinite number of
solutions so the answer is choice D next
problem okay they give us another one
like that they want to know the ordered
pair that's a solution to this equation
I'll just copy and paste the equation
there okay so the easiest thing to do is
probably to just subtract the second
equation from the first equation and
instead of actually write it out
explicitly so the first equation is X
plus 3y is equal to 7 instead of
subtracting this one from that well
let's just multiply the second equation
by negative 1 and then we'll add the two
equation so if we multiply this bottom
equation by negative 1 we get mine
sex minus 2y is equal to minus 10 and
the whole reason I'm doing that is I
know when I add these two left-hand
sides the X and the minus X are going to
cancel out and then I can just solve for
y that's why you know you immediately
see oh they have an X and X if we
subtract this from that they'll cancel
out so let's so if we add these two
equations the X's cancel out 3y minus 2y
is equal to Y and 7 minus 10 7 minus 10
is equal to minus 3 fair enough and now
we could substitute back in to figure
out an X so let's use the first equation
X plus 3 times minus 3 we figured out
what Y is is equal to 7 and then you get
X 3 times 5 minus 9 is equal to 7 X is
equal to add 9 to both sides of this
equation X is equal to 16 so the
solution is 16 comma minus 3 x + y and
that is choice D alright problem 37 37
Marcy has a total of 100 dimes and
quarters if the total value of the coins
is 14 - 5 how many quarters does she
have all right so let's let's say that D
is a number of dimes and Q is the number
of quarters so if you take the number of
dimes plus the number of quarters she
has a hundred coins right that's this
piece of information right there and
then the total value of the coins well
it's going to be it's going to be 0.1
zero times the number of dimes plus 0.25
times the number of quarters and they
tell us that that is equal to 1405 1405
and so and that's this piece of
information the total value of their
coins is 1405 and they say well how many
quarters does she have so we just have
to solve for Q so let's do that
so if we want to cancel out the DS what
we could do is we can multiply this top
equation by let's say minus 0.1 right
and I'm doing that so it cancels out
with this this D right here and let me
do it in a different color so if I
multiply that top equation times minus
0.1 I get minus 0.1 D minus point one
we've got right one zero if I want D
minus point one zero
q is equal to what's minus 1/10 of 100
well it's minus 10 right - 10 100 times
0.1 is 10 and this we're doing a minus
point 1 all right now we can add these
two equations Oh point one D minus point
one D those cancel out point two five Q
minus point one Q that's equal to let me
switch colors that's equal to 0.15 Q is
equal to and what's 1405 minus 10 well
that's equal to four dollars and five
cents just to get rid of the decimals we
can multiply both sides of this equation
by a hundred right so we'll get 15 Q 15
Q is equal to 405 and then we just say Q
so Q would divide both sides of this by
15 and so what is how many times is 15
go into 405 15 goes into 40 what 2 times
2 times 15 is 30 you know 10 105 15 goes
into 105 seven times I think 7 times 5
is 35 7 times 1 is 7 plus 3 is 10 right
27 so Q is equal to 27 so Marcie has 27
quarters
anyway see you in the next video